we've talked about things that might
drive inequality
things that thomas picketty refers to as
forces of divergence but now let's think
about or at least what some of what he
cites is forces of convergence so forces
of convergence or things that might make
the world
a more equal place and the primary one
that he cites is one that's very close
to my heart and this is the spread of
knowledge
spread
of knowledge
and what we have here is a couple of
charts that show the spread of knowledge
at least on a
macro basis on a regional basis and show
how it has has been a driver of starting
to equalize global output as we start in
1700 we see that it's going from 1700
through the industrial revolution
frankly as the west was developing or
industrializing the west europe and
america became a larger and larger
percentage
of global output and asia became a
smaller and smaller percentage but then
as you go into the second half of the
20th century and into the 21st century
you see that dynamic change asia asia's
asia's percentage of world output is
increasing more and more and that's
arguably happening because you've had a
transfer of knowledge a diffusion of
knowledge from the west to the east
to the east for modern manufacturing
techniques and design techniques and
engineering techniques and whatever else
and that's why as we are in the
beginning of the 21st century asia is
turning into a major industrial
powerhouse they've learned from the west
and in some dimensions are even
improving on some of the dynamics from
or some of the knowledge from the west
to to make themselves more and more
productive so at least on a regional
basis this shows that the world is
becoming more equal because of this
spread of knowledge and we could also
see it on a per capita basis so this
right over here this is global well this
this is they're essentially plotting
over time per capita gdp is a percentage
of world average so the world average
the world average right over here is
obviously a hundred percent of the world
average so that's why it's just a
flatline at 100 percent and we see as we
go through the industrial revolution
europe and america essentially the west
the west its per capita gdp becomes a
larger and larger percentage of the
average per capita gdp for the globe but
that was true until recently until the
last few decades the last few decades as
a percentage it's gone down that doesn't
mean that it's that per capita gdp is
going down it just means that it's its
share as a percentage of world average
is going down and that's really because
asia asia's per capita gdp has been
growing even faster because of once
again that spread of knowledge so at
least this this idea of spread of
knowledge it does seem to be playing out
at a regional level
it's bringing at least right now it
seems like asia is participating much
more than africa but it's starting to
bring
the non-west i guess you know the east
more in line with the west in terms of
productive capacity and and and wealth
per person and per capita gdp however
you want however you want to look at it
now an interesting question that's at a
regional level what about an individual
level and we'll talk about that more in
the next video